اللي صار امر لا يتخيل عقل ولا منطق لانه
احن قاعدين سالمين وسالمين في الدار لا
بنطلع ولا بننزل ولا اننا اي حركه يعني
القضيه مش قضيه عقاب القضيه قضيه تهجير
القضيه قضيه انت قاعد في دارك ممنوع تقول
في دارك لازم ترحل على الشعال الجنوب
والله ما نرحل والله ما نرحل والله ما
نرحل اليوم احنا ضربنا صوابنا واستشهد ابن
ابني ممكن ابني في بناتي لكن والله لارجع
على الدار باذن الله وصفونا مره ثانيه
بنلاقي الرب سبحانه وتعالى شهداء ما
بنلاقي ربنا شاردين هذا قدرنا والله والله
له والله ل نتراجع فليعلم هذا النتن هذا
الحقير بان عزيمتنا اقو من صواريخهم والله
والله عزيمتنا اقوى من صوارم ان اخذوا
ابني او ابن ابني او اخذوا نصي او اخذوني
كامل والله لن اخرج باذن الله وسابقى صامت
ارض
رباطه
ا